acquamadre bella a tutti ragazzi
benvenuto che sono video sono felice
oggi siamo tornati sud penombra
necrologi
mamma mia che setup ragazzi oggi
vinciamo webcam incredibile questo il
primo video in cui realtà la sto
pensando e poi magari avete già visto in
altri video sta webcam però questo è il
primo video in cui effettivamente la sto
testando ed è una bomba
comunque erano rimasti ragazzi che
c'erano dei ragni grossi questa qua e la
stanza di fianco allora privacy che
c'erano dei ragni giganteschi nel
corridoio io vorrei evitare di
incontrarli visto che erano andati b4
permessi go allora generator room a
sinistra quindi stanza del generatore
vediamo se riesco per qualche strano
motivo ad attivare la corrente anche se
dubito è chiuso ovviamente devo usare il
pannello perimetro ed ai ed è quel
codice maledizione avevo trovare un
codice
come non detto scherzavo nella mappa già
scritto più o meno agli archivi trovo la
password gli archivi destra sinistra che
quindi a destra sinistra oppure la
stanza della sicurezza vediamo cioè
proprio nella mia vita non posso fare
niente se non soffrire e morire va bene
giovanni buongiorno l'orco demonio cose
qua questa roba qui sotto una trave un
sapone bello sangue se mi spunta un
ragno vi spacco tutto ciò il sapone di
pulisco le porte piuttosto che o mio dio
signor etico molto buono successo
eccola qui la stava aspettando signori
il mio più fedele alleato in questo
videogame è esattamente la carta
igienica che userò per proteggermi da
qualsiasi c'è un laser cellula ma scusa
mi ama mi fa male ma la carte getta la
carta igienica non si è fatta niente
tanto non si stoppa neanche come lo
disattivano con queste cose ai
dell'esclusivo se proprio ci riesco io
faccio così infatti capi dai hanno fatto
un sistema di sicurezza che è veramente
inguardabile permesso bene è stato molto
più easy di quanto pensassi va bene
board cava che mi sono tirato una
portata in faccia salve mamma mia che
casini nostro posto la funzione giorno e
non so neanche dove devo andare però
cioè proviamo proviamo porti a casa
salve la vera mente si apre questa di
storia sì però non è che è diventato un
gioco di james bond questo cioè fatemi
capire un bidone di nuovi laser ma non
vedo nessun esplosivo vicino a loro non
sono pericolosi come sembrano ma guarda
io eviterei anche che dice questa roba
qua a serve per far passare ok ci sta un
porco demonio mi sono cagato addosso
grazie dell'abbonato magari non
facciamolo in un momento in cui
ma sempre giustamente come faccio a
saperlo non so cosa devo fare qua
questo devo andare di sopra non devo
andare di troppo se non ci sarebbe il
suo casino che è successo è chiuso da
via v profonda degli archivi bloccata
alla porte automatiche non si apriranno
senza elettricità devo trovare la kicker
presente nella stanza in sicurezza
cs qualcosa di utile dietro ma ho chiaro
non so neanche come vi giuro ci ho messo
un'ora non anche capito come ho fatto
l'ho ritrovato il video grazie a dio va
bene ci ho messo un'ora e mezza la presa
d'aria è tenuta a malapena insieme devo
cercare i rom per la va bene a posto a
romperle cose ragazzi si mette un attimo
il resto che è un casino
vabbè e chissenefrega se manda non ho
capito cosa mi è servita sta roba però
ho trovato un condotto vamonos allora
dove infilo si visivi ma tu sorella non
avremo niente detto va bene fanno
schiaccia è nata in arena lo sapevo ci
sono bisogna dire che vuoi
bruciati allora questa è la corrente che
non funziona perché manca diffusibili
che però io ho già tutti e tre perché
sono forte 1 21 dosi 3 se va vano tutto
sto casino
se però non funziona c'è un senso ma non
esisteva il bottone era finto ma dai che
pirla si è attivato no glielo attivato è
cioè senso e vedere
vedi cosa vuol dire prima bisogno di
accendere il pane ma c'è la presa della
corrente a la spinella è staccata la
spina ella scusami acceso ok tutto
giusto questo qua comunque non
funzionano e distrutto a prescindere
obama non sia devo far arrivare tutti
cosi minchiam enigma ci manca solo
questo
ce l'ho fatta subito proprio lui lo
risolve va bene quindi generatore c'è
quindi adesso sentiro questa cosa torna
la corrente magica ascom e tre magi kurt
beck l'ho fatta per una volta nella vita
riesco a fare una roba mi scusi ma che
può fare quello che vuole nome mi scusi
eh si faccia i cavoli suoi per favore
chissà chi era il suo tizio c'è qualcuno
c'è nessuno
raga ho visto gente porco demonio vabbè
adesso comunque funziona st romano più
tiro la leva e non so non lo so perfetto
non so neanche che cosa ho fatto
50 per cento andiamo anche al 100 grazie
non 50 per cento a vela riva bene mi
accontento del 50 per cento cento per
cento a posto
attivato il generatore tutto funziona
qui adesso o riattivato la corrente
ovunque sono bravissimo mamma mi ha
permesso mammamia stesso brutti sti
corridoi oggi su p no questa cosa non
deve succedere
salve buongiorno specie un'ascia la
prendo grazie la usiamo la usiamo questa
shahla usiamolo usiamolo scusami e non
vorrei guardarti troppo in fascia lo so
che sei hai fame di cervelli però non
riesco a non mi dai una mano a uscire
per favore kilt aiuto non fa niente fa
qualcosa fa perchè non era possibile
cioè scusami non è possibile qualcosa fa
però che c'è un coso attrezzo per la
presa d'aria bene sei lì per favore 6 di
questa non si stacca me non lo
stacchiamo presa d'aria questa
ho sentito che ha urlato ti muovi a
svitare veramente non mi ha fatto nulla
che strano puoi tenerti questa grata per
favore si è fatto male la tiene lì
apposta
ciao e stato molto divertente amico mio
molto divertente ragazzi sto sentendo
dei rumori incasinatissimo buongiorno
ragazze ha finalmente si è svegliato pip
che non è sempre lo stesso sono più pif
oh mio dio
ok ho sfidato giorno poiché sono posso
tappare il buco che mi caga un podio
grazie a era la porta di prima ok che se
adesso non sono così stupido da entrarci
va bene fa niente
magari no ma io non mi fa schifo
che brutto gioco visto uscire il dio che
pronta facendo quella porta dio che male
fa niente va bene non importa aiuto dio
no ragazzi cioè non posso basta vita ma
io ero andato ma che male tu sorella
morta che male
porca vacca ragazzi è rimasto di lama
tipa guardalo guardalo che non aspetta
guarda che schifo oddio che vita brutta
amico ce n'è un altro di coso di
condotto spettri che io stavo io con gli
ospito le cose che vedo è utile mannaia
mamma mia che gioco ansiolitico come la
vita che faccio se sta roba di ogni pool
a key card chiave magnetica ua un'altra
vittima del cianuro
e chissenefrega d'aiuto la key card
andiamo facciamo il giro non ho idea di
dove sia andato non lo voglio sapere la
verità è già difficile così non ci
aggiungiamo i ragazzi per oh mio dio mio
dio che si guarda stai di azzardare è
mamma mia che fastidio via corri qua
tutto acceso la tessera la tessera usa
lac entra non so neanche cosa serve st
porta però va bene conosce una
ricetrasmittente nell'era di un monitor
delle camere camere sorveglianza bello
se dice qua dentro
simpatico bella questa foto mi piace
ragazzi bel sempre allegri con le
polaroid e portatela anche i raduni che
funziona non so bene cosa mi sblocca
starò lavoro one belva swanson ciao zia
vuoi la cena senza lei è proprio
interessato a me per l'est cinerario
c'era c'era un'intesa l'ho presa bene
quindi io vado basso dall'altra parte
aspetto ok posso uscire
mamma mia che ansia però in tutto questo
devo andare dall'altra parte tutto qua
niente di più semplice non ci fosse
stata la radio stanno trasmettendo
maschile trovato grazie questa qua
immagino subito tram ciò che scoppino si
aprì le porte così grazie ragazzi bene
siamo quasi in dirittura d'arrivo
abbiamo fitto il gioco non è vero
brother la gente che carina mi dava una
mano almeno finalmente non devo
cavarmela da solo beh almeno e allegro
almeno noi ragazzi è un po sordo ci sono
i ragni lo dico non me lo sento dentro
se ci sono io vi ammazzo cos'è quella
roba lì c'è qualcosa di giu il porto
birillo e non posso portarmi evidente
va bene ma se io vado qui in mezzo mi
succede della roba immagino ma non mi
succede niente però convinto mi facesse
male piuttosto casinò c'era una creatura
abnorme lì c'è prodotta proprio non mi
piace questa faccenda vadano avanti se
mi spunta qualcuno vi ammazzo ma nessuno
adesso è pochi forse nessuno posizionata
più o meno bene sai vediamo eccolo
proprio lui ce la fa
no non è vero la maschera antigas e il
sud alla fine mi serviva ragusa promessa
mamma mia che ansia o mio dio ce l'ha è
impossibile cioè fatevi fatto lo dire
impossibile tanto c'è anche quella
creatura di prima poi c'è un cestino
dio mio l'ansia di vivere
era questo il posto questo era il posto
brutto che intendevano prima mamma mia
se non so neanche vedendo dovreste
andare ma fatto incredibile vedere stai
zitto che già è difficile
no è la porta chiusa e non ce la faccio
sono morto la porterà ho trovato la
porta chiusa tra tutte le cose che
doveva succedere non doveva succedere
questa cosa tratta la porta chiusa se
corri forse ce la fai
se corri in forse ce la fa ce la fa ce
la fa ce la fa ce la faccia a faccia a
faccia peggiore
ti prego di miele portaperta aiuto non
sono morto impossibile già faccio
neanche imprecando in cinese
c'è una porta lì c'è una porta lì e
rossa e rossa promette male poi ci provo
[Musica]